Speaker 1: I'm actually not going to be covering
yesterday's mass shooting in San Jose, California,
because I have quite literally nothing to
say about it that's new.
And what I mean by that is it's another shooting.
We've had like a dozen in the last week or
so.
We have no political will in this country
to do something about gun violence, not all
of us.
But because Republicans have so much power,
they don't want to do anything about it.
You have a movement which wants more guns
out there every single time there's a mass
shooting.
And I can't think of anything to say since
we've covered so many of these shootings.
But there is an ancillary story related to
yesterday's shooting that I do want to cover.
Retired New York Police Department Detective
Pat Brosnan was invited on Fox News to comment
on yesterday's mass shooting, and he bizarrely
blamed coronavirus vaccination for the shooting
and said you can bet the shooter himself was
vaccinated.
Now, I couldn't believe this was possibly
an actual analysis being made by a real guest
on Fox News, one of the three major cable
news networks in the United States.
But it happened.
Let's jump right in and you will quickly see
that Pat Brosnan appears to have something
not functioning quite right in his brain.
Speaker 5: Good morning.
I was actually in a rational world where there's
adherence to the rule of law and respect for
law enforcement, say, pre the summer of love
of 2020.
I think there would be more nuanced response
in terms of opening a shooting, an active
shooting right next door to where there's
a load of armed professional shooters under
law enforcement.
But the rules have changed.
You know, crimes are no longer illegal.
There's no longer enforcement of lots of laws
and there's an empowerment of these active
shooters.
Speaker 1: So, first of all, how could a former
police officer make such a silly analysis?
If people still respected law enforcement,
no mass shooter would even think to start
shooting near a police station.
The shooter plan to die.
What does he care if there are police nearby?
And what is Pat Brosnan mean?
Crimes are no longer illegal.
By definition, crimes are illegal acts.
But is he saying we no longer prosecute crimes?
Just from hearing this part?
It was off to a bad start.
But then he gets into vaccination
Speaker 5: and, you know, how is this is a
crime that I wish I was wrong with my prediction,
which I mentioned to anybody who would listen,
that once once college starts to lift, these
cowardly shooters will come out exactly in
tandem with the number of vaccinations.
You can be sure they probably got vaccinated.
They were just scared to come out and they're
coming back.
And you see the numbers don't lie.
The shootings are up dramatically skyrocketing,
actually, an act of shootings throughout the
United States as we've come through this pandemic.
It's really terrifying stuff.
Speaker 4: You know, as we listen to that
very brief news conference, one of the things
that I picked up on,
Speaker 1: so the hosts there, Harris Faulkner,
has nothing to say about this absurd hypothesis.
He says, look, mass shootings are increasing
as vaccinations increase, mass shootings are
increasing as people are gathering in groups
publicly.
Again, Pat Brosnan is acting like his prediction
was notable in some way.
I've been saying on this show, many others
have said we are seeing mass shootings increase
again as things are reopening.
Mass shootings are standard operating procedure
in the United States.
Sadly, tragically, disgustingly, when people
go back to work, when people go back to commuting,
when people go back to socializing, as we
exit the pandemic, there have been and will
be more mass shootings.
It's not vaccination.
And at the end, he's really off the deep end
because he says, I bet you this shooter was
vaccinated.
First of all, at this point, everybody should
be vaccinated.
And what I mean by that is we've had more
vaccine supply and demand for more than six
weeks now.
Most of those who aren't currently vaccinated,
they're not necessarily anti vaccines, but
they've not yet been determined enough to
go and get a vaccine because they could have
done it.
OK, but he seems to be suggesting that the
shooter was waiting to get vaccinated before
doing the mass shooting.
The shooter appears to have planned to die
yesterday.
If you plan to either shoot yourself or get
police to shoot you after shooting up your
workplace, why are you waiting for the vaccine?
Maybe you want for your workers to be coworkers
to be back at work so that you can have a
bunch of them together to shoot.
OK, yeah, that may be something you're waiting
for, but what a completely harebrained idea.
And this is by far the stupidest way I've
seen to criticize vaccines from from the entirety
of this pandemic.
If there has ever been a cautionary tale about
understanding the difference between correlation
and causation, it's looking at an example
like this.
Mass shooters are not notoriously fastidious
about being vaccinated before going out and
doing a mass shooting.
There's just that that's not the case.
And then it's also important to mention implicit
in his argument is that coronavirus shutdowns
are good in terms of they limit mass shootings.
My guess is this is not a guy who is too thrilled
with coronavirus guidelines, just from how
he talks dismissively about vaccination.
But what he seems to be saying is when we
were, quote, locked down, which we never were,
it actually did work to decrease mass shootings,
which is an interesting thing to hear from
a guy who is making no sense about any of
his arguments.
Disgusting, sick argument to be making
a